زمن ما بعد الحرب البارده قد ولى هكذا
اعلنها وزير الخارجيه الامريكي اذا في اي
عالم نحن الان وفق المنظور الامريكي خصوصا
انما تشهده اقل من حرب عالميه واكثر بكثير
من حرب بارده الاجابه قد تكون في موسكو مع
تاكيد رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ان سنوات
العشر المقبله لن تكون هادئه وكما اشتهر
ميدفي صراحته وتواضعه دبلوماسيته يقول
بالحرف هناك دول لا تفهموا الا لغه القوه
زامنا مع ذلك لا تزال تداعياته زياره
الرئيس الصيني لموسكو تقلق المسولين
الامريكيين وخصوصا وزير الدفاع
فقد قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الوضع
القائم بعد الحرب العالميه لم يعد موجودا
وانا ثمه منافسه شديده جاريه لتحديد ما
سياتي واكد بلنكن في كلمه امام الكونجرس
الامريكي انه واشنطن تريد ان يتشكل عالم
حر ومزدهر وفق تعبيره
اجتماعنا اليوم ياتي في لحظه فارقه فقد
ولى علم ما بعد الحرب البارده وهناك
منافسه شديده ايجاريه لتحديد ما سياتي بعد
ذلك ولد الولايات المتحده رؤيه ايجابيه
لذلك المستقبل الا وهو عالم حر ومفتوح
وامن ومزدهر
من جانبيه قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ان زياره الرئيس الصيني لروسيا ارسلت
اشاره مقلقه للغايه واكد ان الصين تمثل
تحديا متزايدا لبلاده وضفا اوسن في جلسه
لمناقشه ميزانيه البنتاغون عقدتها لجنه
المخصصات في مجلس النواب الامريكي انا
واشنطن تستثمر في وضع قوه اكثر مرونه
بمناطق المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وزياده
نطاق التدريبات مع شركائها
ميزانيتنا مدفوعه بالاستراتيجيه وبجديه
منافستنا مع الصين
وستساعدنا هذه الميزانيه على مواصله تنفيذ
استراتيجيه الدفاع الوطني لعام 2022
واستراتيجيه الرئيس للامن القومي لدي الان
ثلاث اولويات رئيسيه في البنتاغون الدفاع
عن امتنا والاعتناء بقواتنا المتميزه
والنجاح من خلال العمل الجماعي والصين
تمثل التحدي المتسارع الذي نواجهه ونحن
نسعى جاهدين لمجارات ذلك التحدي
هذا وقال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي دي
متر
المقبله لن تكون هادئه بسبب رغبه الغرب في
الهيمنه وراى ان بعض الدول تفهم ولا
تستمعوا الا للغه القوه لذلك لا فائده من
الاتفاق معها كما حذر من ان توقيف الرئيس
الروسي
في الخارج يعادل اعلان حرب على روسيا حسب
تعبيره
بشكل مفاجئ يتخذون قرارا بحق الرئيس
الروسي ولنتصور ان رئيس دوله نوويه وصل
الى المانيا وتعرض للتوقيف تكون هذه
الخطوه اعلان حرب على روسيا وفي هذه
الحاله كل وسائلنا من صواريخ وغيرها ستطير
مباشره الى مكتب المستشار الالماني